[Music]
foreign
this is your Tech news briefing for
Friday July 15th I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal
it's been nearly five months since
Russia invaded Ukraine and as the war is
unfolded it's taken an immense toll on
Ukraine's people and its economy
a key sector that drove the economy
before the invasion was Tech
Ukrainian exports of I.T Services had
been on the rise with the trade group
I.T Ukraine Association reporting an
increase from 4.2 billion dollars in
2019 to 5 billion in 2020 and 6.8
billion in 2021.
so what impact is the war having on
Ukraine's Tech sector and what does its
future look like
for a first-hand perspective I'd like to
welcome Andrew pavliff the CEO and
founder of NX a software services
company with about 2 000 employees in
Ukraine many in leviv and Oleg roginski
CEO of people AI which builds software
to improve sales and productivity using
artificial intelligence while the
Ukrainian founder has based his business
in Silicon Valley people AI had nearly
50 workers in Ukraine before The
Invasion Andrew Oleg thank you for
joining me so thanks for having us thank
you for having us okay so you guys know
a lot about the Ukrainian Tech sector
and I think a lot of our listeners have
become much more aware of how robust the
the tech sector in Ukraine was at least
before the War I want to talk a lot
about what's going to happen to that
sector going forward but first can you
guys tell me what it was like when
Russia first invaded earlier this year
Andrew what was going through your mind
when this happened and how did you deal
with it for your company
yeah we were prepared I would say
because rumors were around the news were
around and we sent maybe two weeks
before to our employees on the East
warning to evacuate but nobody did but
when War started and in that morning we
had about like 200 of our employees
moving from East and some from Kiev to
Western Ukraine together with their
families so we had one week of moving
people and accommodating them in Western
Ukraine what did that mean for your
company I mean how did you continue
operations at all while you're moving so
many people yeah we send a message to
our clients that Services might be
interrupted during that time and then
actually in one week we were back to
almost 90 percent of our services so
people tend to really focus on work
and they understood the importance of
keeping your economy alive in that
situation oh like you're based in the US
but you have a lot of uh Ukrainian
workers what was it like for you how did
you prepare well back in December I
started a daily stand-up with my HR and
Technical team leaders literally working
out every possible detail about what
happens if the war starts for example we
had our employees vaccinate their pets
in case they're bringing their pets with
them during evacuation abroad we had
them figure out who they're going to
bring with them how many cars they need
we even printed out the routes from Kiev
and other places and had them have a
printed folder of how they're going to
drive in case internet in the country is
offline
and that work continued through December
and January and around January we
actually made a decision a month before
the war started that we're gonna
activate our BCP plan and evacuate and
so we had probably 80 percent of the
team moved to Zagreb in mid-January
and so do you still have workers based
in Ukraine now less than a handful
talk about the situation now I mean
Andrew you said within a week you were
back to being operational has that
continued uh through the war through
attacks that Russia has been you know
focused on in different areas of the
country
yeah actually like as most of our people
were created to Western Ukraine some of
them also abroad about like 200 people
or like appeared to be abroad so they
did it before a war but uh as our
company became fully I would say remote
since covet times so kovit prepared us
very well to that kind of situation and
clients was also ready to work remotely
with all the people so people just
changed their place to Safe places in
Western Ukraine and they continue
working
oh like you said most of your staff has
left Ukraine do you think you would move
them back or ask them to go back
well there is two aspects to that after
Zagreb we invited them to join us in
Prague where we actually have acquired a
company that was based out of Prague so
all of the infrastructure and benefits
and payroll everything was already
working and set up in Prague for us in
terms of coming back there is a number
of issues there to be honest for example
our business insurance doesn't cover
employees who are in Ukraine any longer
because it's an area of active conflict
so from compliance perspective with the
requirements of our U.S customers we
need to be much more precise and very
off the restrictions that are now
imposed on doing business inside Ukraine
which is very unfortunate
but outside of that one day we do hope
to return when it is safe and when
employees can safely continue working
there
versus what it was like before The
Invasion you're both saying you know our
businesses can manage we can keep
providing the work that our customers
want but certainly this sector can't be
the same as it was before The Invasion
can it definitely we have some
decreasing of speed of growth or 480
sector in Ukraine but I think we are
speaking about like we expected to grow
50 before a war and now we will grow for
25 percent so anyway there will be grow
also having a lot of people without jobs
I think we will have a lot of switchers
to ID industry because it Industries
still can employ people in Ukraine and
companies have active vacancies active
positions on the market and people want
to go to work to it we see a lot of
people who are switching to it at the
moment in Ukraine I know like what about
from your perspective how does the
Ukraine Market before the war compared
to what it's like now well for us we are
a little bit of a different business
profile Andrew is selling ID Services we
are a product company so for us the
product is being developed the same
product we are selling to worldwide
corporations is being developed
regardless of where the people are
from in terms of what changed obviously
recruiting has become a bit harder we
had an amazing pipeline in Ukraine of
all of the engineering talent that was
there and now we have to rebuild that
pipeline in Europe I guess but our
Canadian Toronto and San Francisco
officer stepping up especially as uh as
kind of the economy is lightening up
here there is more availability of
talent in North America
do you think you know foreign
governments or the Ukrainian government
could do more to help the tech sector
unfortunately I do think that uh it also
depends on the industry if you are in
for example Enterprise B2B focused
industry customers like stability safety
predictability Etc so in that case while
we expected some impact we didn't see
impact of customers being worried about
Ukraine I was actually very surprised by
how customer base rallied up and as long
as we're communicating that our teams
are safe our data is safe we are in
European union and there is not much
exposure if any to the war there hasn't
been a change in demand or customer
requirements for us I do feel the factor
of safety is going to be playing out for
Ukrainian economy at Large
you're there on the ground is there and
more that you think foreign governments
or I guess even
sector there
foreign tech companies are helping just
because they work with us and we didn't
lose any clients since War started which
is it was not surprised for me I did
expect that actually that we will have
support when we see in support of the
world for Ukraine yeah definitely some
of them want to diversify their risks
but it's more like long-term strategy
and nobody drops us when war begins so
companies are helping and if I can send
a message to to foreign companies work
with Ukraine because as Oleg mentioned
there is plenty of talents that we can
hire and these talents are really
available in Ukraine so into your
previous question of what western
governments can do for Ukraine I
actually have
have thought about this the amount of
technical talent that is learning to
both on the front lines and in the back
office basically learning to operate
quickly iterate and apply their
technical skills to solve problems is
tremendous in Ukraine right now what I
think will be very helpful for Ukraine
after the war and this is where people
can easily help is a functioning and
thriving Venture Capital ecosystem
before the war started there were four
or five Venture funds all sub 100
million dollars that were investing in
Ukraine some of them have gotten good
returns I would love and my dream is to
help bring back venture capital to
Ukraine at much larger scale
when the war is over because there's way
too many talented entrepreneurial people
there that need backing
I mean not to be too
time so if it continues is there any way
to to Really rebuild Ukraine's Tech
Market to what it once was or to the
potential that people thought it might
have
I'll give you a an interesting answer I
would have loved to put in a seed
investment check into all of Israeli
companies in the 70s
I would be very rich right now if I did
it
so similarly whoever comes back and
funds the next crop of Ukrainian
startups will probably make a lot of
money
I take to return Ukraine's Tech Market
to what it once was and to the potential
it was seen to be having
yeah like here's two perspective one
from service business I think service
business can rebuild itself pretty fast
after War finish but regarding the
Venture Capital trust and the startup
ecosystem is definitely a much bigger
problem at the moment and the second is
after War I believe Ukraine is under
this resilience that we are having since
2014 and then the core of it and this
kind of War it's an entrepreneurial
Nation that's why I also believe into
into way of Israel for Ukraine where we
have a self-defense entrepreneurial
nation that can do Innovation and I see
a lot of innovation related to military
stuff at the moment we are working in a
few projects here is a lot of startups
in that area that get financing at the
moment robotics is growing here and like
the different kind of robots that can be
applied for a war field so it's happened
at the moment so I mean Ukraine have the
cool potential and it have to be
supported after War because we can be a
good player on that market yeah and uh
just to that point the backbone of
Israel's Tech was idea of people who
graduated from fighting and went stayed
back in Israel Defense Forces and did
all the computer security Advanced
Weaponry Etc and then from there most of
cyber security companies in the US today
either come from Israel have massive
representation in Israel
well here's a simple example everybody
thought that cyber warfare is going to
take Ukraine down take it offline make
the country go dark
when Russia attacks it didn't happen it
didn't happen either either Russians are
bad or ukrainians are really good
ukrainians are really good
so guess what back to Israel analogy if
ukrainians are really good there's a
bunch of cyber security companies to be
built out of Ukraine
Andrew Oleg thank thank you so much for
joining us for this discussion thank you
sir yes thank you for having me
and that's it for Tech news briefing
this week our producer is Julie Chang we
had production assistants from Ariana
osparu our supervising producer is Chris
Tinsley our executive producer is Katara
yoga and I'm your host Zoe Thomas thanks
for listening and have a great weekend
[Music]
[Music]